you're in Vegas you sign up now suddenly
everyone wants to be there I have to
imagine you've met some very like
impressive people oh it's crazy yeah
it's and know it's fun it's even fun for
me like I people say you know been in
Show Business whatever you call it I
think I'm in Show Business you're
definitely in Show Business I was say
I'm I'm in some I'm close to it if I'm
not in it you're definitely in it um you
get to meet people that's probably the
coolest thing you know you're backstage
and you're talking to sting and you're
you know yeah you're you're having a
just the queen yeah you know that was
probably the one of the pinch me moments
would they would would you ever like do
you have any rules like if someone like
that is in the crowd do you want to know
or do you just let it that's funny you
ask I used to I used to not want to know
okay and and then I now now I want to
know because I I don't get as nervous
and and worked up about it as I used to
right so I would say I like we had you
know sting came and shy Twain was in the
thing I said they told me you know I
said thank you because I wanted one I
wanted to kind of this what cuz I might
have a bit Yeah so usually if someone
comes they're in the show regardless and
until they know it and they used to
happy with it but Shai Twain was there
and I'm like I and I did this bit before
she I'd ever met her and this it's a
horrible it's all these songs she sings
and I said every song's like a
cheerleader and you play there's like
five or six songs you play
it let's go girls and then the next song
is and it's all all right let's go so
it's so funny in the show so I said I'm
just going to my my crew is like you
know what are you going to do with the
Shai thing she's there I'm like [__]
doing it what do you mean what are you
going to do yeah that's why we do this
yeah so she's sitting right there and I
do it all she just and the first line
out is shai2 I'd hit that again and so I
get this like kind of weird laugh from
the crowd and then and then her
husband's kind of like after show she
comes back and she's like you'd hit that
again and I said yeah you'd hit it again
I said yeah and fr's like like you can
hit it again I said yeah so she we
became that's that big friends because I
you know cuz I made fun of at the show
and she she just you know I didn't call
her out either I didn't tell her anybody
she was there I just did the bit not
told her cuz uh um she could you get a
said it I said no I'm to let you enjoy
your night but then it comes we had Tony
Orlando last night wow and uh he does
the tie yellow ribbon around the old so
you know the whole when I go into the
audience to do little crowd work I I go
through and I'm like what the [__] Tony
Orlando's here and you know Play the
song and we have a little piece of
yellow ribbon and I [__] with the you
know I [__] with the with the crowd and
so it becomes part of the whole show so
you embrace it now Queen was probably
the coolest though cuz Queen came back
there and they were just like you know
[__] it's Queen right yeah it was a
little ner I was not going to lie I was
a little nervous and and I have some
Queen in my shows a lot of Queen song
there's even a clip of when Freddy says
[__] you to the crowd I do this whole
show and then afterwards you know they
come back and I'm like oh my God Queen's
in my dressing room and
um the drummer Roger says uh Scott that
was just God damn that was funny right I
said oh thanks he says no that was
really how do you [__] do that this
is crazy and Brian May stand there and
he's like they're both they both just
are like in awe right and it was very
sweet of them they were just like they
wouldn't stop talk and Brian is really
he knew like every little he said and
that thing the part that you did with
the with the thing and the video came in
how did that how did you do that and I'm
like well and they go to leave and he
says
um I hate to do this to you but is it
okay if I come back tomorrow wow and I
said to my show I said what you don't
have to come back to my show Noor he
goes no I want to my son is flying in
tonight and I if if it's okay I want to
bring him back I want to bring him
tomorrow and I
thought absolutely but I mean you know
are you sure you want to do that and he
said to to to my assistant on the way
out he says um we'll get yall hooked up
and I overheard him say I just got I got
to come back and make sure this wasn't
for like this was for real wow he didn't
believe it the show was so good and so
tight he's like let me see this again
wow then he then he told me the next day
he says yeah I actually wanted to see it
cuz I could I didn't believe it wow and
I was like really CU yeah it was too
good so I'm like okay then he came back
and said it's [__] bloody amazing
yeah but he you know you know one little
you know I added one little one like
Trump thing one thing like and just he
knew exactly I though the Trump thing
was new yeah so yeah
just to how do you do
that here's here's how you always tell
me how do Trump you just got to lean up
like that right just be
mad right just mad just and both thing
just scowl now you hate me right yeah
and then just just just uh just say
anything is like they don't have carp no
one had carpeting I made carpeting like
you didn't make car there's never a
carpet there was never chairs before I
was President I was the only president
with tables no no one had tables if you
remember they didn't there was no tables
there was no
glasses and you're like no there there
was F no no one sat no one
sat I did it
all you're not the first one I'm the
first one I I am the greatest ever you
you seen kp's Dick it's better than that
did he always talk like this cuz I feel
I know it seems like he became more of a
caricature yeah like it kind of started
with caricature more like it never
started out that way
I think you're right it just started
rolling leaving the sentences longer
like there's things you know I didn't he
he he honed in on his performance he he
saw what people were yeah and he kind of
made character of himself yeah probably
I think probably we all I I don't go
back and look at my clips of me doing I
probably I've evolved well hopefully
evolved gone backwards but changed I
mean God it's you know it's like listen
the fingernails on a chalkboard
listening to myself and like everybody
in you know our Seno Hall Show I'm like
here's a cup with a thing on it you know
I think it's you know I think the
coolest thing that I guess that I hear
just in this 40 minutes we've talked so
far is it doesn't seem like at any level
of career like anyone ever feels like
I'm oh yeah I'm I'm set as in sort of
like you always still have that part of
your brain that's like is this good you
know do people like this oh I think
that's probably the kiss of death for
every every every artist I think yeah um
because you never you know what the next
you know you can't live off the neck the
last thing you did is the it's like the
shows it's like you know this the other
night we had a we called a road show so
what that means is you know Road shows
are usually really R Rowdy and loud and
fun and you just you're like a rock star
yeah and Vegas shows can be but you
could also be you know it could just be
a show well a lot of of tourists right
but there's been some amazing show been
amazing um shows with that we've had but
the other night we had a whole I don't
know two or three in a road that we just
we come out I said [__] I even said
it for the show I said we need a road
show yeah and we came off and first
thing everybody says was Dude Road Jo
and I said and you can't predict how and
why it just happens it just the crowd
was just great electric and which makes
you dance more it's weird like there's a
dance that you get up there with when
they're good you're good it's just it's
like
it's golden yeah every comic knows that
and in any profession actually you're
selling cars you get on a roll and
you're selling car I God dang I'm
selling 10 cars today because I just had
a rhythm yeah so it was really just in
in comedy but but but when you get those
moments and then you start that's when
you start thinking God damn I'm I'm
really I I think I finally got this I'm
really good I feel like that dance is
what escapes people when they watch
standup and I feel that cuz I you know
I'll talk to people and or I'll see
people say online like I don't like
standup or I don't get it or I think
stand Up's kind of this and I think
people especially young people now they
kind of see standup in a weird way where
it's just like you know little clips of
crowd work and they go oh why do people
like this and I feel like people they
don't know and people tell me that by
the way all the time and I'm a comic
yeah they say I hate St comic yeah I
always find that funny but then and I'm
like oh oh geez I'm you don't like I I
hate what you do like oh like what me
personally or just no just comenting El
just eh I'm like oh okay well definitely
don't come to my show yeah yeah but yeah
people all the time I don't like or or
you know that' be just BR honest I mean
no one comes up to me and says they
don't like me but what they'll say is I
never liked you but now I love you like
kind of
thing